I want to add one last thing here--the initial robot location.
If we define x0 to be 0, which is the origin of the map,
then what this means is we add 1 over here and 0 over here.
The reason why is this constraint is that x0 is 0.
Let's take a robot moving around and let's say it sees a landmark
from the first pose x0 and from the third pose x2 but not from the second pose.
I want you, in this matrix over here,
to check mark all the fields that are being modified by Graph SLAM--
it's a binary check--and the same for the vector without putting actual numbers in.
So go into this matrix and ask yourself which fields will be 0, the ones untouched,
and which ones will not be 0 that are the ones we modified.